interruption volontaire de grossesse les
députés votent demain aujourd'hui le bas
près vif many people qui est michel
debré en iran situation de plus en plus
confuse l'amérique profonde unis
derrière carter le drame du cambodge
pourquoi l'aide internationale n'est pas
distribué 1 messieurs bonsoir un horaire
inhabituel pour un rendez vous auquel
vous êtes de plus en plus fidèles nous
reprendrons dès demain nos bonnes
habitudes de 20h mais ce soir vous le
savez les programmes d'antenne 2 sont
modifiées 20h sera à l'heure du rendez
vous que nous avons avec le chef de
l'état pour la quatrième émission du
type une heure avec le prise en mains
publiques
ce soir c'est au tour d'antenne 2 et je
crois que toutes les interventions c'est
sans doute celle qui aura été le plus
attendu elle survient en effet dans un
contexte international bien trouble et
nous allons parler tout à l'heure mais
aussi au lendemain de remous ce dans la
vie politique française ces remous ont
touché le président la république
lui-même
on attend donc beaucoup de sa prestation
face à jean pierre elkabbach alain
duhamel et gérard saint paul sur place
paul amar l'entretien se déroulera ici
dans le petit salon rouge c'est le nom
de cette pièce de l'hôtel marigny situé
en face de l'elysée est réservée
habituellement aux chefs d'état
étrangers en visite en france
vous l'avez dit patrick cette émission
est la quatrième du genre les
téléspectateurs en connaissent le
principe
pendant une heure le président de la
république répondra aux questions de mes
confrères aux questions que les français
se posent et aucune de ces questions ne
sera élu dé la situation économique et
sociale
le climat politique qui règne en france
l'évolution des rapports entre les
partis de la majorité de l'opposition
après le vote sur le budget la
disparition tragique de robert boulin
tous ces événements devraient permettre
au chef de l'état de faire le point sur
l'état de la france
et d'insister sur le fonctionnement des
institutions son intention expliquer
mais aussi informer il est possible que
pour valéry giscard d'estaing le moment
soit venu de faire justice comme ils
avaient précisé
des assertions le concernant je parle
des diamants de bokassa
mais le président de la république
devrait également faire le point sur
l'état du monde
et parlera des événements qui auront une
incidence sur la vie quotidienne des
français l'iran le proche orient les
problèmes énergétiques et l'europe enfin
une europe qui s'interroge sur son
propre avenir et dont la cohésion est
aujourd'hui menacé par l'attitude de la
grande bretagne
voilà tous les sujets que le président
de la république devrait aborder à 20h
sur antenne 2 dans en moins de 30
minutes
c'est à dire donc tout après ce journal
il est aussi tout à fait possible que
valéry giscard d'estaing aborde le
dossier sur lequel travaillent les
députés depuis ce matin ils viennent à
l'instant d'interrompre leurs travaux il
s'agit vous le savez de l'avortement ou
plus précisément de l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse
notre service politique résume pour nous
ce débat en conscience et non selon leur
appartenance politique c'est ainsi que
les députés depuis ce matin sont invités
à se prononcer sur la reconduction des
lois et veille
monique pelletier qui défend le projet
de loi aujourd'hui n'hésitent pas à s'en
prendre à ceux qui s'opposent à la
libération de l'avortement peut être
contre l'avortement et pour une loi qui
encadre sa pratique et je demande
je demande à tous ceux qui se proclament
contre la reconduction de la loi ce
qu'il propose à la place ils ne me l'ont
pas dit mais le ministre déléguée à la
condition féminine n'a pas oublié non
plus dans son réquisitoire
ceux qui souhaitent une banalisation du
bg je le dis solennellement si le texte
de la loi est reconduit le gouvernement
prendra un ensemble de mesures
complémentaires que je vais vous
proposer
destiné à assurer une exacte application
de la loi toute la loi
mais rien que la loi bref monique
pelletier demande aux députés un vote
clair en insistant toujours sur la
notion clé de la loi de 75 la notion de
détresse en insistant aussi sur la
prédominance des hommes à l'assemblée
nombreuses sont les femmes qui vont
observer cette assemblée très masculine
vous allez débattre
d'un problème qui est d'abord le leur
les femmes les femmes n'ont pas tous les
droits parce qu'elles sont des femmes un
jean droit à votre confiance en leur
capacité d'assumer leur décision elles
ont le droit de vous demander de ne pas
le juger au nom du gouvernement je
défendrai ses textes de loi avec tout
mon coeur et toute ma conviction mère de
famille j'ai eu la chance et je dis bien
la chance de pouvoir mettre au monde
sept enfants pas un instant je
n'oublierai que cette chance que j'ai
eue ne donne le devoir de comprendre
celles qui connaissent la détresse en
début d'après midi michel debré pose la
question préalable
il souhaite ainsi que la discussion du
projet sera renvoyée car pour l'ancien
premier ministre ce n'est pas la loi de
75 qui est mauvaise c'est l'application
qui en est fait depuis lors nous voyons
bien que notre législation médicalisent
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
mais sans qu'un service social soit prêt
à accueillir la mer et assurer la vie de
l'enfant avec compréhension avec douceur
avec respect
cette interruption volontaire de
grossesse elle répète pendant cinq ans
n'a nullement été un acte exceptionnel
comme le législateur l'avait été décidé
mais dans plus de la moitié des cas a
été en fait une chine opérations à la
convenance du couple de la femme
après avoir entendu à nouveau monique
pelletier la question préalable et
repousser le débat se poursuit donc et
la parole est alors donnée aux deux
porte parole de l'opposition de femmes
pour nous
la contraception et l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse sont liés et ne
saurait être divisée
car c'est de la bonne connaissance et de
la bonne pratique de la contraception
que l'on peut espérer que les
interruptions volontaires de grossesse
ne deviendront qu'exceptionnel et il
vous faut bien l'audace
messieurs et mesdames de la majorité
pour multiplier les alarmes à propos de
la dénatalité alors que vous avez
soutenu en tout point la politique de
monsieur bart qui en trois ans de bons
et loyaux services rendus au grand
capital a réussi deux ferme
ap remonter l'inflation à 32,8 vous n'en
est pas fière il n'y a pas de quoi et
madame jacques députés socialistes et
madame moraux que nous l'entendons
député communiste alors daniel brême
autant que vous sachiez nous arrivons
presque au terme de ce débat ce que la
loi va passer ou pas au terme ce sera
demain soir dans la nuit peut-être au
petit matin
mais la loi devrait passer et c'est le
scrutin sur la motion debré qui a donné
des indications en effet 17 rpr sur 154
paraissent favorables au projet et 77
udf beaucoup plus que la fois précédente
sur 120 +2 non inscrits ce qui fait 80
c'est soit pour la majorité ce qui n'est
pas suffisant mais le groupe socialiste
a d'ores et déjà annoncé qu'il voulait
des modifications à la loi mais que de
toute façon il voterait le texte pour ne
pas revenir en arrière
donc de toute façon on peut parler d'une
majorité sans doute confortable et bien
écoutez les socialistes font planer
l'incertitude et georges fille lui a dit
que le groupe socialiste plus le bureau
du parti déciderait selon les
amendements qui libéralise la loi
seulement demain soir mais la grande
majorité des députés socialistes
devraient voter ce texte
donc il devrait être voté je vous dis au
petit matin de la nuit de mercredi à
jeudi donc dans les autres groupes pas
de troubles de conscience pour l'instant
non pas pour le moment
merci daniel les événements d'iran est
tout d'abord cette dernière dépêche qui
ne consomment pas l'iran pardon mais
l'urss parce qu'elle n'arrive à
l'instant il s'agit de l'élection d'un
nouveau membre du politburo monsieur
nicolaï tikhonov qui a 74 ans qui a été
donc élu membre de plein droit du
politburo du parti c'est-à-dire l'organe
gouverne l'urss avec comme membres
suppléants nicolas et gorbatchev 48 ans
évidemment il s'agit d'une élection qui
prend plus de relief à un moment où l'on
parle beaucoup de la santé défaillante
de messieurs brejnev et conseiller les
événements d'iran donc comme promis avec
tout d'abord ce que j'ai appris peu de
temps également avant ce journal une
nouvelle intervention principe la
dernière
ils y allaient être pratiquées sur le
chat à new york intervention réussie
s'agissait de l'extraction d'un calcul
biliaire en principe désormais plus rien
ne s'oppose à ce que l'ex empereur
quitte les états unis
aussitôt sa convalescence se terminer
deuxième élément celui là plus politique
une déclaration de jimmy carter c'est
une mise en garde adressée à l'ayatollah
khomeini ne croyez pas que la libération
des otages terminera la crise ouverte
par l'occupation de l'ambassade
américaine à téhéran
précision du porte parole de la maison
blanche la libération des otages dans
l'esprit monsieur carter ne voudra pas
dire que l'art d'oise a été nettoyé
jimmy carter s'exprimer devant un petit
groupe de sénateurs américains
certains vont encore plus loin en
amérique ainsi ce general motors ancien
responsable de la cia qui a dû en faire
bondir plus d'un hier soir dans question
de temps réécouter le plus écoutez moi
je ne peux pas parler au nom du
gouvernement je sais que je suis
aujourd'hui un officier à la retraite je
suis un citoyen particulier mais
l'ayatollah ferait bien de ne pas
sous-estimer la colère croissante du
peuple américain qui s'est sentie
bafouée et humiliée et ne le laissera
pas continuer éternellement
et c'est vrai que ces propos du nord
reuters reflètent assez bien l'état
d'esprit d'une partie de l'opinion
américaine qui depuis le début de cette
affaire s'est considérablement ressouder
derrière le président carter regarder le
résultat de l'enquète de jacques séguin
et jean-louis saporito
si on n'y prend garde on peut avoir le
sentiment que les événements d'hier en
laisse les américains indifférent
préoccupé déjà par les achats de fin
d'année
et pourtant moi je pense de cette
étudiante qu'il suffirait de détruire 10
% de leurs champs pétroliers et de leur
demander au bout de 24 heures s'ils sont
prêts à négocier un accord de parme
je vois que nous et méricain on se
remonte et que c'est une événement qui
ne rassemble que puissent tous ensemble
en face de cette crise
et même s'il fallait faire une
intervention armée vous seriez d'accord
avec cette intervention armée
personnellement non mais de ma famille
oui ce n'est pas le moment d'être démuni
devant la tragédie
il faut se serrer les jusqu'au moment où
le problème sera résolu
je tremble à chaque fois je pense qu'on
aura une autre guerre ou quelque chose
comme ça
jamais les églises américaines avaient
connu une telle affluence trois semaines
jour pour jour après la prise d'otages
de terre
à
ap rome l'aficion dit qu'elle vient de
recevoir un message du chargé d'affaires
à terrain prisonniers l'humus
il demande à tous de prier pour
qu'américains et iraniens se
réconcilient il demande aussi que les
cloches de toutes les églises sonnent
pendant dix minutes à partir de midi
chaque dimanche et tant que les otages
ne seront pas libérés
les américains ont suivi la consigne
avec une unité voir une ferveur comme
s'ils ne doutaient plus de même
retrouvant le rythme des années 60
illustré par le fameux monument aux
marines qui rappelle que la valeur au
dessus de la moyenne est une vertu comme
les américains qui rapatrie encore
certains de leurs diplomates dans
plusieurs pays islamiques pour éviter la
répétition d'incidents semblables à ceux
d'islamabad
du côté iranien maintenant d'abord cette
mise en garde des étudiants islamiques
attention les bâtiments de l'ambassade
américaine à téhéran sont minées si vous
tentez quoi que ce soit tous autres a
dit style osé minc et certains d'entre
eux devant cette même ambassade vous
allez le voir se sont flagellées
publiquement les images qui montrent
qu'ils sont eux assez impressionnante et
coutumiers en cette période de l'année
en iran
comme nous sommes à la veille d'une fête
religieuse c'est la raison pour laquelle
les étudiants craignent de l'état n'a
qu'un utilisent ce moment pour
intervenir au niveau officiel cette fois
la confusion des esprits et extrême
voilà maintenant qu'on nous dit que
l'iran est prêt à participer à un débat
complet au conseil de sécurité des
nations unies à partir du 1er décembre
et que monsieur bani sadr viendra bien à
new york
on verra pendant ce temps le
porte-avions kitty hawk poursuit son
chemin il est maintenant arrivé dans
l'océan indien et se rapproche très vite
de l'iran alors tentera-t-il de forcer
le fameux détroit d'ormuz qui ferment
vous le savez le golfe persique
en tout cas la flotte iranienne est en
état d' alerte comme philippe rochot
notre envoyé spécial là bas a pu le
constater
cet homme que vous venez de voir ces
l'amiral madani commandant en chef des
forces navales iraniennes qui un stock
qui inspecte ses navires nous sommes en
effet dans la base navale de bandar
abbas à l'entrée du golfe persique dans
le détroit d'ormuz ce goulot
d'étranglement de 40 km de long qui
contrôle toute l'entrée du golfe
persique
cette position est doublement
stratégique d'abord c'est l'entrée des
eaux territoriales iraniennes et d'autre
part c'est aussi la route du pétrole
puisque un navire pétrolier toutes les
10 minutes passent en effet par le
détroit d'ormuz
autrement dit si les américains qui
disposent de deux porte-avions
de l'autre côté de cette entrée du
détroit d'ormuz intervenait et bien la
route du pétrole serait coupée pourtant
malgré l'état d' alerte qui règne dans
cette base de bandar abbas
on n'a pas l'impression d'une opération
militaire américaine imminente
c'est ce que nous confirme l'amiral
armée de madani et nos bars etc qui
avaient en moins de gauche toutes nos
bases navales ne sont pas au même niveau
d' état d' alerte mais on peut passer
rapidement à l' alerte maximum nous
sommes sont prêts à se battre
nous ne serons pas sûrs mais je pense
que ça n'est qu'une menace américaine
c'est un show politique alimentaire et
sarenza ans - didier marie l'amiral
madani depuis six mois à la tête de la
marine iranienne est l'héritier de la
flotte de guerre la plus puissante de la
région
malgré leur envoie des conseillers
américains les forces navales sont
restées intactes mais l'embargo des
etats-unis sur les pièces de rechange
pourraient se faire sentir d'ici
quelques mois
pourtant la marine iranienne estime
qu'elle peut résister suffisamment
longtemps pour créer une crise mondiale
en cas d'intervention américaine
pour être complet sur le dossier il faut
dire également que du côté des émirats
arabes
on annonce que la production pétrolière
va être réduite de 5 % à partir du 1er
janvier
mais là pour des raisons strictement
technique et enfin pour l'arabie
saoudite rien n'est terminé dans la
sphère de la grande mosquée de la mecque
puisque selon certaines sources les
rebelles retranchés dans les sous sols
ne serait pas une poignée comme on
l'avait
10 mais bien deux sens c'est une
affirmation bien sûr à confirmer cette
députée udf se reviennent du cambodge
c'est la première fois depuis cinq ans
que des hommes politiques français ont
pu ainsi se déplacer à l'intérieur du
cambodge
le but de cette délégation est temps de
vérifier le bon acheminement des vivres
et médicaments destinés au peuple
cambodgien acheminement qui ne l'aura
pas paru satisfaisants l'un d'entre nous
disait d'ailleurs à midi pas plus
d'ailleurs qu'au docteur kouchner
l'animateur de médecins sans frontières
qui lui aussi revient d'un hôtel on ne
sait pas où cette nourriture va aller en
réalité les entrepôts sont pleins sur le
port en tout cas nous avons des chargés
sur des camions et sur une barge
cette barge est parti et ni nous ni le
comité international de la croix rouge
et l'unicef avec lequel nous travaillons
ne peut dire où cette nourriture va être
distribué donc vous ne pouvez pas
contrôler véritablement savoir si l'aide
que vous avez apporté sera distribué aux
population cambodgienne je crains même
de pouvoir dire que elle elle ne sera
pas distribué elles s'entassent pour le
moment en tout cas il n'y a pas de
contrôle possible malgré les efforts du
comité international de la croix rouge
qui souhaiteraient le contrôle est donc
la première chose a mis à dire à mon
avis c'est que cet immense aide
internationale ces millions de dollars
dépensés ne peuvent plus aller à
l'aveuglent n'importe où il faut qu'un
contrôle soit instituée par la
communauté internationale par des
journalistes par une commission denquête
qui comprendrait des gens qui par
exemple ont lutté contre la guerre
américaine au vietnam qui sont pas
suspects aux yeux des vietnamiens et
qu'ils puissent aller voir d'abord s'il
ya une famine deuxièmement si cette
nourriture va aux cambodgiens ce qui
permettrait aux cambodgiens qui reste
qu'ils ne sont pas morts sous polpot de
prendre en main leur propre destin et
d'organiser la distribution ça ça me
paraît élémentaire que de savoir où va
cette mode donc c'est en quelque sorte
une accusation contre les vietnamiens et
vos portes et là je crois que les
vietnamiens organise la disette je pense
pas qu'il ait une famine dans les
régions contrôlées par les vietnamiens
organise la disette pour ce pour se
montrer indispensable pour rester et
pour très clairement colonisé le pays le
problème cambodgiens qui sera le thème
des dossiers de l'écran à 21h avec comme
invité vedette le prince hinoi
il n'y a plus de malaise entre l'espagne
et la france c'est ce qu'a jamais adolfo
suarez à l'issue de son entretien avec
raymond barre nous allons maintenant
avec bruno albin essayer de comprendre
quelle divergences ont été aplanies mais
d'abord écoutant le chef du gouvernement
espagnol chez soares moins de quarante
huit heures d'entretiens auront suffi à
éclaircir les relations franco
espagnoles
monsieur suarez l'a confirmé ce soir au
cours de sa conférence de presse entre
la france et l'espagne 6 et les gels et
mieux les deux pays vont désormais
collaborer dans des domaines comme le
sommaire c'est l'indus aride ces
nouveaux rapports franco espagnole va
également permettre la réalisation de
projets communs de dimension
internationale en amérique latine pas
résisté mais est ce que l'on retiendra
rien surtout c'est que cette visite à
paris du président du gouvernement
espagnol marque dodge et l'haleine d'un
nouveau style de rapports entre paris et
madrid les modèles et les mitaines déjà
fragile avant ses entretiens franco
espagnole on parlait de malentendus et
de grogne
désormais les deux gouvernements sont si
j'ose dire branché sur la même longueur
d'onde
c'est bien la preuve des vertus du
dialogue c'est également la preuve que
la crispation des rapports entre paris
et madrid ne reposait pas sur les
problèmes fondamentaux
tout cela ne signifie pas pour autant
que les dossiers en suspens soient
résolus celui des garanties par exemple
dont la france veut entouré la future
adhésion de l'espagne au marché commun
le oui de la france restent acquis à
condition que cette entrée de l'espagne
dans le marché commun souhaite assortie
de la pause et d'un certain nombre de
garde-fous
on peut en tout cas dire que ces
problèmes ont été cernés et la volonté
manifestée aujourd'hui de part et
d'autre de se rencontrer au moins une
fois par an à paris ou à madrid pousse
bien que l'on est disposé à aller
beaucoup plus loin vers la recherche de
solutions raisonnables pour reprendre
une expression employée ces jours ci à
l'hôtel matignon justice avec le procès
de jean fabre le président du parti
radical italien poursuit vous vous le
savez pour insoumission lefebvre nous
exposer hier les données du problème
on ne saura que tard dans la nuit ce que
vont décider les juges militaires mais
ce que l'on peut dire d'ores et déjà
c'est que jean fabre a souhaité utiliser
ce procès et même son éventuelle
condamnation comme une tribu devant la
passion de cet homme on se sent un peu
gêné jean favre 32 en main ce petit un
visage creusé sous une barbe courte
démontre la dimension dérisoire de
l'homme seul devant la raison ou la
logique des états il dit voilà des
années que je me bats pour la paix
la charte de nuremberg de 45 a condamné
comme crime contre l'humanité
l'emploi de l'armement nucléaire or le
gouvernement français comme d'autres
pays d'ailleurs se sont préparés à cette
guerre il poursuit vous ne pouvez pas
demander à un homme de participer à cela
de se faire complice de cela accepter le
service national du jan fabre c'est
accepter le crime qui se prépare cinq
magistrats de civils trois militaires
sont venus juger un homme qui n'a pas
rempli ses obligations militaires comme
disent les textes se retrouve finalement
devant un accusateur jan fabre
depuis le 1er janvier de cette année 50
millions d'hommes de femmes et d'enfants
sont morts de faim dans le monde
dans le même temps 418 millions de
dollars ont été consacrés à la
fabrication d'armements chaque année
vous acceptez pire qu hitler et staline
réuni mort je n'accepte pas c'est
évident pour cet homme
le tribunal militaire est une tribune
une tribune dont il connaîtra le prix
tard dans la nuit
social deux initiatives de la cfdt de la
cgt d'abord le syndicat de mon maire a
envoyé aujourd'hui une lettre au
président un public cette lettre envoyée
à la veille du sommet de dublin exprime
l'attachement la cfdt à la mise en
oeuvre d'une politique européenne au
niveau des conditions d'emploi et à
propos de la réduction du temps de
travail
la cgt quant à elle l'a demandé à être
reçu par le premier ministre dans les
conflits en cours pas de changement chez
les contrôleurs aériens poursuite de la
grève situation également bloqué à nice
matin le pdg a menacé de fermer
l'entreprise si le journal ne paraissait
pas avant la fin du mois et puis une
grève demain dans les perceptions est
plutôt original dans ses motifs les
agents des impôts réclame entre autres
choses la possibilité de ne pas
travailler le mercredi pour pouvoir
garder leurs enfants
deux versions dans la sphère de l'eau
minérale polluer le conseil général des
yvelines a décidé de détruire le stock
de bouteilles et de fermer les usines de
montigny la direction de fonds tels
conteste ces laboratoires d'analysés
n'ayant rien trouvé de suspect elle
demande une nouvelle analyse les
administrations les commerces et d'une
manière générale tous les locaux ouverts
au public ne respectent pas la règle des
10 9%
c'est en tout cas vrai dans la moitié à
peu près des 5000 administration où la
température a été contrôlé les
particuliers eux respectent davantage la
loi ils sont 64% dans ce cas
transition toute trouvée pour vous
parler de la météo et justement les
températures d'aujourd'hui sur
l'ensemble du pays étaient élevées pour
la saison vous pouvez beger le remarquer
sur notre carte pour demain on nous
annonce un temps ensoleillé sur la
méditerranée et en montagne partout
ailleurs le temps sera nuageux et les
brouillards seront tenaces dans les
vallées ce qui entraînera bien sûr une
baisse de température pour prochain
rendez vous avec l'information tout
d'abord bien sûr le rendez vous avec le
chef de l'état à 20 heures juste après
la publicité
et puis ce soir vers 23h30 à peu près le
dernier journal présenté par hervé
claude journal au cours duquel vous
pourrez bien sûr entendre les réactions
suscitées par le discours de valéry
giscard d'estaing le discours qui est en
fait une entretien avec 3 journaliste
jean pierre elkabbach alain duhamel et
gérard saint paul demain on trouverait
patrick low cost il sera de retour pour
antenne 2 me
à 12h40 bonsoir à tous et à demain 20
heures